Ce qui est bien avec le code de la route
c'est que au moins c'est accessible, c'est ludique,
tu mets pas 3 ans à l'avoir
FAUX!
Alors, faut savoir que les gens du code de la route,
ils ont un vocabulaire bien à eux, tu vois ?
Que nous, les gens de la vraie vie, on utilise pas
Déjà dès le premier jour, la dame de l'inscription, qui remplissait les papiers
Elle m'a posé une question, euh, à laquelle j'étais pas trop préparé...
(Dame de l'inscription) Oui,
Est-ce que dans le passé, vous avez déja été motorisé ?
Euh, c'est à dire ?
Comment ça ?
A quel niveau ?
Au niveau des... Des bras ?
Donc, être motorisé, ça veut dire avoir un véhicule avec un moteur dedans
Chose que tu sais pas forcément quand tu pilotes un VTT !
Ce qui était mon cas !
Ce qui est toujours mon cas !
C'est comme le simple mot "voiture", eux, ils disent pas voiture
Eux ils disent :
"Pour la série de questions qui suit
Nous imaginons que vous utilisez un
C'est parti pour un tour en agglomération !
C'est comme les bosses, sur la route.
Que nous on appelle normalement un "dos d'âne"
Eux ils te disent :
"Dans quelques mètres, vous allez rencontrer un dos d'âne...
...ou un cassis."
Un cassis !
Y a combien de mecs en France
qui disent un cassis ?
ZÉRO !
Personne !
Nan mais tu trouves pas ce mot hyper pas naturel ?
Un cassis...
"Oula, ralentis mec y a un cassis là"
Alors pour moi le cassis c'est ça... ou ça...
C'est quoi ce délire de dépasser les cyclistes
A 1 mètre de distance en ville...
...et à 1 mètre 50, en dehors de la ville ?
Nan mais vous croyez vraiment qu'on va s'amuser à mesurer ?
Ok c'est bon !
Nan mais c'est quoi ce délire ?
Ca veut dire que si tu dépasse pas le mec à la bonne distance, tu vas aller en prison ?
Allô la police ?
On vient de me dépasser de 90 centimètres...
(Bruits de voiture de police)
Ce type est dangereux !
Moi je savais pas que les gens ils étaient
Ils calculaient autant leur gestes dans la voiture...
Heureusement que dans les films d'actions, ils conduisent pas comme ça !
T'imagines, le code de la route dans les films d'actions ?
"Dans cette situation
A: J'effectue un rangement de véhicule
En forme d'épi.
B: Je fais un geste de courtoisie à l'automobiliste en face
Avant de paniquer comme un malade mental.
Le pire dans le code de la route, c'est quand ils te parlent de drogue au volant
Tu sens que le mec qui lit les questions
(Rire) Il est plutôt à l'aise avec le vocabulaire des jeunes !
Vous êtes sous l'emprise d'un pétard à base de résine de canabis
Vous êtes donc sous l'emprise de la drogue !
Très important, la spirale dans les yeux
Cet à dire que... Il doit te montrer que le mec
Il est vraiment pas bien !
Quand tu fumes... T'es pas bien !
Dans cette situation :
A: Je dépasse
B: Je fais tourner
C: Je m'en... bas les c*******
D: AIGHHHTTTT
HAHAHAHA !
Ah mais les mecs du code de la route, c'est des psychopathes hein !
Attends, leur passion, c'est quand même les panneaux
Faut pas l'oublier !
On à tendance à l'oublier !
Des fois je me dit : le monsieur qui fait la voix dans le DVD du code
Il est comment avec sa femme, le soir quand il rentre euh...
Chez lui ?
On fait l'amour ?
Oui réponse "A"
Non réponse "B"
En même temps sa femme c'est
Peut être la dame qui lit les question aussi...
Oh oui réponse A!
Moi y a des fois j'aimerai bien être à la place de Sergi
Lui au moins il a pas besoin du code, il s'en fout, il se déplace comme il veut !
Vous êtes de plus en plus nombreux sur ma page FaceBook "Norman fait des vidéos"
Ça me fait tellement plaisir
Je fais un petit vœu pour vous
Vous êtes double-super !